Oh, Clovers,
just like that.
Hey, hey, hey.
You got to leave Clovers alone.
First of all, it's none
of your business
what Clovers and me do.
Secondmost,
it's his idea.
We're trying to have
a gentle, romantic moment here.
Oh! Whoo!
(Forrest voice-over)
This inmate, an armed robber
named Cassius,
may have started it,
but in no time at all,
sex with Clovers
had become the new prison slang
for masturbation.
[prisoners shouting]
Everybody all at the same time.
How is that even possible?
(Cassius)
Get the balls, Clovers.
Oh! Oh!
(Forrest voice-over)
I had now had enough human
contact with my fellow prisoners
to know that I much preferred
to be left alone
with my imaginary friend.
Hey, Clovers,
forget about MacNeil.
Come over here, play a little
Connect Four with me.
Yeah, Clovers says,
"No, thank you," okay?
We're having
a good time.
Whoa, and here he comes.
My man, Clovers.
(Forrest voice-over)
It appeared that Clovers
had now become a symbol
in a prison yard
power struggle.
Cassius wanted to show he could
take whatever he wanted from me
whenever he wanted.
Oh, Clovers,
that was mean.
You just tricked Cassius that
you were gonna go play with him,
and now you're coming back here
to play checkers with me.
Oh! Oh, snap!
You were only
tricking MacNeil
into thinking that
you were tricking me.
That's a double cross.
You're a bad man.
You're a bad man, Clovers.
The triple cross?
Unbelievable!
I mean, he really,
really thought
that you were gonna play
Connect Four.
Quadruple cross!
And what are you doing?
Putting an electromagnet
in your pants
so you can't get up off
of this metal seat?
Five cross?
Unbelievable.
And the magnet doesn't work.
I understand you have to stay
in contact
with him so you can
eventually murder him.
Maybe you're intimidated,
you feel like you have to
go over there
but there's no reason for that.
Guys like this
are all bluster.
What you really would like
to do is dance?
- Come on.
- Be careful. Leave me alone.
[laughs]
Dance-off, MacNeil.
Oh, get 'em, Cas.
[laughter]
Pardon me, may I cut in?
- Thank you, yes.
- Oh!
Come here, buddy.
Oh, you don't like that style
of dance?
Oh, traditional Irish
step-dancing?
I don't know but I'll try.
Oh, you're really good at it.
Look at you.
Nobody likes feeling
like a leprechaun.
Time for break dancing?
Oh, break it out, MacNeil.
Who thinks that Clovers wants
to be my best friend?
- Yeah!
- Looks like he made his choice.
- Then circled the table.
- He made his choice.
- We're gonna play checkers.
- Taking a lap
to think about it.
Here he comes around here.
- Look it. There he goes.
- The rude faces you're making.
Oh! He just put a yellow in!
Oh! He didn't do that [bleep].
- You put that yellow there.
- [shouting]
[guard blows whistle]
- You put it there.
- [shouting]
Visiting hours.
MacNeil.
You got one.
- [bleep].
- There he goes.
[shouting]
[laughs]
- After you.
- [bleep].